tonight we begin a three-part regulation
nation series by looking at the Trump
administration's rollback of many
education department policies of
correspondent Doug mackelway tells us
there is a lot of red tape to cut
through I am challenging my cabinet to
find and remove every single outdated
unlawful and excessive regulation
currently on the books few federal
agencies impose greater bureaucratic
burdens on the interests they oversee
than the Department of Education created
by President Carter in the Democratic
Congress in 1979 even the New York Times
at the time and it tore alized against
it saying education quote will continue
to do better without a central
bureaucracy more than 30 years later the
Department of Education has
fundamentally changed education
especially higher education since 1996
college tuition has skyrocketed 200% far
beyond inflation and most Consumer
Services we literally have not just more
administrators than faculty there are
more administrators than there are
personnel at universities doing teaching
research and service and they're all
getting paid decent salaries so as a
result costs go way up the payoff
graduation rates have declined now 59%
among students seeking the four-year
degree lower still for minorities and
student loan defaults are soaring an
issue the administration tried to tackle
when it proposed capping student loan
payments at 12.5% of income and
forgiving the debt after 15 years to us
and to the American public regulations
are actually the public protections we
depend on education secretary Betsy
DeVos has begun rescinding many federal
mandates for higher education but has
also tried to tackle the issue in lower
education often too intense opposition
gone under the Trump administration
Michelle Obama's school lunch program
chocolate milk is back also gone
accountability programs like No Child
Left Behind and the race to the top
transgender bathroom guidance has been
cut and most controversial divorces
withdrawn college title nine standards
for sexual misconduct leaving it denied
the accused fundamental due process
we're in the midst
of the me2 moment people are paying a
lot of attention to sexual violence and
harassment and so it seems a surprising
choice courts appeared to be vindicating
de Vos and her push for due process now
those students are suing and the
universities are losing sometimes to the
tune of really big damage Awards in
federal court so far real courts of law
have set back 79 campus guilty verdicts
one analyst notes that judges are losing
patience with skewed College proceedings
under title 9 right Doug thank you